what we will not do is we will not break
the countdown's over Todd and Julie
Chrisley reported to prison you don't
lie you don't cheat you don't steal the
Chrisley Knows Best Stars face a whole
new reality starting their combined
19-year sentence for bank fraud and tax
evasion they're appealing those
convictions but now the couple will
plead their innocence from behind bars
we file for an appeal and by the grace
of God our truth
wins we made a commitment that we were
not going to give up leading up to
Tuesday the Chrisley's request for bail
was denied along with an 11th Hour
attempt to delay their surrender date
the reality of it for me is that when
you know you did not do these things
that's a hard pill to swallow their
illegal hot water started in 2019 when
they were indicted on 12 counts of bank
fraud tax evasion and wire fraud
prosecutors said Todd and Julie took out
over 30 million dollars in fraudulent
loans to fund their lavish lifestyle we
grew up in a very small rural town and
now our main home is 30 000 square feet
this is my closet things are organized
by season we signed up for a show that
has entertained millions and millions
and millions of people but what we
didn't sign up for is to be lied on in
et's exclusive sit down they denied any
wrongdoing at the same time though there
have been reports of you having said I
just fix it fix these documents fortify
these documents that's not true the
stars were found guilty last summer
these were very serious crimes the fraud
was extensive Todd was sentenced to 12
years Julie seven years both Chrisleys
face 16 months probation upon leaving
prison yes what we're going through this
storm that we're going through
it's bad and would it be as hard if the
truth was out there no one of the things
that the courts are supposed to take
into account when they sentence is the
deterrent effect and when it comes to
things like bank fraud tax evasion and
things that the Chrisleys were convicted
of it's sending a message to the
community at large that these crimes do
not go unpunished meanwhile the couple's
children look to an uncertain future
thinking of mom and dad not being cured
during certain life events and until I
know that they're going to be there yeah
I can't get married I can't have a kid
the family's reality shows Chrisley
Knows Best and growing up Chrisley both
canceled by the USA Network Todd was
also set to host a speed dating series
that too got the ax God didn't bring us
this far to drop us off but the
Patriarchs got high hopes for a new
Venture the documentary that we're
working on right now is going to be very
talent and their legal battles next
chapter I've never seen two people not
parents be so steadfast in their faith
in the end the truth will prevail may
get harder before it gets easier but we
have faith